judgement was one of the best games of
2019 and now it's remastered for current
gen consoles
to celebrate here's a side-by-side
comparison of the original version
running on ps4 pro and the new version
running on ps5
this video will only take place within
the first 30 minutes of the game and
includes load times
scenes fighting detective work tailing
people and a chase sequence
so you don't need to worry about
spoilers the original ps4 version ran at
30 frames per second and the new ps5
version goes up to 60 frames per second
so you'll definitely notice that one is
smoother than the other
if you like this video and want to see
more comparisons then consider
subscribing to gamespot
so without further ado take it away
yagami
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes yes i understand completely
we'll absolutely be able to help you out
with that
i guarantee you
oh you must be talking about yagami
absolutely we appreciate any interest
you might have
[Music]
[Music]
come in kaito-san are you getting close
yet
yep right by the don quixote
heading your way now you just about see
our man
yeah i got him he doesn't have a clue
huh
ah you're getting good at this almost
like a pro
wow thanks i always dreamed of being a
professional stalker
i'm not sure i'd call it that you gotta
admit this is crazy though
a detective tailing another detective
you only see that [ __ ] on tv crazy or
not
stay focused
[Music]
oh
hmm
[Music]
found him finally i thought you were
never going to catch up man
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
there it is hold on i'll send the feed
here
[Music]
hey
are you serious i didn't track you down
just so you could
maybe next time what
ah kidding me
[Music]
he's making a run for it i saw where are
you going little guy
damn it get back here
you won't get away from me
hold up
you won't get away
stay away from me don't be so
melodramatic
i think we both know who threw the first
punch oh no way i'm gonna let that slide
just you watch you'll see the court's
gonna
huh but that's
a lawyer's badge so you're not a
detective
and you still want to sue
you know you won't know what hit you
thanks for watching if you like this
video then consider dropping a like we'd
appreciate it and for all things
judgment and yakuza stay tuned to
gamespot
[Music]
[Music]
great
[Music]